Johnny Depp sent us in a photo Thank You
Johnny the x-ray envenom face been
caught off of a blow-up doll
trying to fight the Hulk from a fried
walk I want to get to know you bro
that won't be there brother you scare me
man back off this is the you know a lot
of people were saying they wanted an
r-rated venom I think he's gonna done it
is now with it I came back has given us
the x-ray in venom gave smash that and
you left it I wonder what the suits like
from the back that's not something I
think you I think we all know what that
says you have to pay to subscribe you
have to subscribe to see what the suits
that we make absolutely if I saw kmac in
the corner of the Moon for me it would
be perfect you would be 92 stayed in the
corner of the room I would just maneuver
through the room yeah you wouldn't even
notice
I'd appreciate the create calendar yes
but I wouldn't want any part of that
came up do you want to come over for a
cup of tea bro you're welcome I want to
get to know you bro that won't be there
Johnny
yeah we've given call me in ages it's
gonna and why wasn't I invited to come
there that looks like an old Edmunds in
the Deaf anyone he startled from for one
of the chuckle brothers Phillip
Schofield on the right but with a mask
on he's weird because the Donald Trump
mask looks like it's been cut off of the
face been cut off of a blow-up doll you
know it's a very disturbing situation my
reaction to this is undisturbed I'd
imagine I was about to say this is a
really bad venom costume it looks more
like Enid Scissorhands
he's known that why is he not dressed as
venom
he's winning as Edward Scissorhands like
look if he is but why is he not dressed
as venom because he's winning as Edward
Scissorhands and that's enough we not
here to promote Edward Scissorhands here
to promote venom Adam is no competition
is he I know it is Edward but we're in
character it's the wrong character
venom please what's that favorite horror
movie I used to watch The Nightmare on
Elm Street so much I was 6 years old
explains it up messed up screwed me up
that dancer vampires over 6000 dancing
vampires yeah no really no special Ben
Welch good name I think it's honorable
it's with noble intention horrible I'm
just confused because isn't the one like
one of them is where you know it's this
super woman isn't the WWF logo that's
one little slug is it okay I thought it
was like Ultimate Warrior meets Wonder
Woman WWF like a little bit her name
William was true by plastic so this is
interesting because one of the nukes
that venom and the top off second off
bottom off like I said looks like Uncle
Michael and the guy on the other side
actually doesn't like venom but is an
amazing way of Skeletor name is Dan Cox
I'd agree Johnny Depp sent us in a faux
Thank You Jenny
that's so cute he's gonna speak yours
isn't it yeah what a pair of contact
lenses fixed one would you like venom to
meet any of the other Marvel superheroes
gonna fight the Hulk from a front wall
as Eddie Brock as venom that's that's
definitely out there right everyone's
gonna find the Hulk you know for me on
tumblr I'm relaxing
Alan Carr Oliver Buckley we never got to
him
you
you